[Music]
yes
very good
[Music]
minor
me too
[Music]
do
can you hear me
no
you can
yeah
test test oh there we go
hi good evening welcome to the table we
are small but we are mighty right
so glad you are all here with us tonight
and
a warm welcome to those of you that are
joining us online we are so glad you're
here
my name is karen
and i just have a couple of
announcements uh to get us kicked off
tonight
first of all we are having our welcome
to the table class
this evening immediately after the
service
we've got some food and we've got some
great information from brett
so
whether you rsvp'd for it or not
if you'd like to be part of the welcome
to the table class you can do that
tonight uh what that is it's just an
introduction to
who we are
a little bit about our guiding vision
and mission and values a little bit
about where we're hoping to go as a
church
what kind of community we are
it's just a great class to get all of
that information so for those of you
that did sign up yay
great choice and
yes yes we support your decision and uh
secondly if you didn't sign up but
my speech made you want to sign up then
you can join
my persuasive speech
then you're welcome to join the class um
and again that'll be immediately after
uh the service and you'll just go right
into this this door the room next to us
for that
secondly uh we are having our state of
the table meeting that will be on sunday
september 12th
and that's basically like a family
meeting where we talk about how we're
doing as a church we talk about
our ways that we're connecting as a
community our our goals for the short
and long-term future
we also talk about our financials so we
want to be as transparent as possible
about how we're doing as a church and so
whether you're a member or not you are
welcome to attend so that'll be sunday
evening september 12th immediately after
the service
all right how about
we pray because if there was ever a week
to pray i think i think this is it so
let's take some time
just take a breath
take a breath
still yourself
and let's center on god
god
here we are again so much has happened
um there's a lot going on in our world
right now at the macro level and at the
micro level
so
god we give it all to you it's too much
for us to carry
so this is one of those times that we
anchor
on your hope
your grace your mercy your comfort your
strength your peace
god fill us with your spirit
help us to
yeah let go where we need to let go
to be present where we need to be
present
be courageous where we need to be
courageous to rest when we need to rest
and to trust you god
we trust you
we pray for those god who are grieving
who are walking through loss
we pray for those
who are in the midst of
national tragedies
climate disasters
and just everyday stress god
we lay that all down at the cross
and we remember god that you are good
that you are with us you never leave us
and that we are never alone
so god help us to rest in that tonight
help us to center on you
help us just take a breath
and remember that we are yours
we give tonight to you god
and we give you our hearts
in jesus name amen
[Music]
all right
well we are
grateful to be together that's for sure
i'm
so
privileged to gather um
especially
with weeks like these um
i was just
sharing that
um this week has involved i've never had
a week where i've had people both close
to me and just acquaintances so many
that are either hospitalized or
dying or
having family members that are close to
them dying it's just
been weighty it has been a weighty space
and in the midst of that when melody and
i got together
um
on whatever day that was
you know we're carrying it all in our
hearts and um this is not one of those
weeks where this worship set is going to
be the perfect like setup for brett's
sermon
it's more so a response of our own
hearts posture where both of us said
like these are one of those times where
you need to look to something that's
bigger and firmer and more trustworthy
than the circumstances that are going on
around you
um you need to be able to find the
anchor in the midst of you know what i
mean everything that's swirling
um
so that's where we're
that's where we're at tonight and um
i can't look at melody
there's been too many tears this week
guys
um but if you guys will stand with us or
you're welcome to sit if that's
where your heart's at
and we want to look to god together
right now that's um where we're at we're
looking to him and
kind of taking shelter shelter
in his shadow
so
[Music]
let the king of my heart let the king of
my heart be the mountain where i run
the fountain i dream from
oh he is my
song
let the king of my heart be the shot
where i hide
ransom for my life oh he is my song you
are good
you're good
[Music]
you are good
you're good
[Music]
let the king of my heart
be the wind inside my sails
the anchor in the waves
[Music]
you are good
you're good
whoa
you are
good you're
[Music]
you good good
you're good
[Music]
you are good
you're good
[Music]
you're never gonna let me
you're never gonna let me down
[Music]
you are good
you're
[Music]
you're good
you are good
[Music]
we just want to um
take space before we get too much
further to
um go ahead and pour out our prayers
before god and lift up the burdens on
our hearts to him
so that we can come to him in complete
honesty
and um
yeah
i'm gonna go ahead and um
lead us out in the prayers of the people
and um if you guys will repeat after me
um
we'll
pray through those
things together and then we'll leave
some space at the end
to just speak out the things that
are going on in our own lives or the
lives of others that we want to
pray about together so
for this city of saxi texas and for
every city and community
and all those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us
and the wisdom and will to conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land
sea or air
we pray to you
for the old and the sick
for the widow and orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and oppressed
the unemployed and destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all who
remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
and so
we lift these names and these situations
up to you
[Music]
from online
nancy starting chemo
people impacted by the hurricane
and chris
[Music]
those in the spears household
ron and betty jones
do
for all those who are
suffering by themselves and in
quarantine
do
these names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those that we have kept in
our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
we're going to do a new song tonight
it's not new to the age but
new to this community and
it's a song i learned 10 years ago
and at the time i was in a
school of ministry kind of thing and it
has been the song that i kind of
any time that i feel stressed or i feel
like i don't have any foundation under
me
it comes into my brain and it's just it
pours out of me
um and the song is called god i look to
you
and there's a chorus in it that
will sing hallelujah our god reigns
and
um
something about hallelujah is
so powerful and so simple the word
itself
but it always does something in my
spirit
it lifts
my spirit just to say the word
hallelujah
it's almost a
declaration that there is something more
there is something greater there is good
there must be good sometimes there must
be good god
but uh i just encourage you guys to
we'll be repeating a lot of it so
it's pretty simple but just to sing it
out
and with your voice
declare that that hope in your life or
in those you love
for their life
[Music]
god i look to you
i won't be overwhelmed
give me vision
[Music]
to see things like you do
god i look to you
you're where my health comes from
[Music]
give me wisdom
you know just what to do yay
[Music]
and god i look to you
i won't be overwhelmed
[Music]
give me vision
to see things like you do
god i look to you
you're where my help comes from
give me wisdom
you know just what to do
and i will love you
lord my strength
and i will love you lord my
[Music]
forever all my days i will love
thank god i look god i look to you
i won't be overwhelmed
give me vision
to see things like you do
god i look to you
you're where my health comes from
give me this
you know just what to do
and i will love you lord my
strength
shield and i will love you
lord my strength
forever all my days i will love you lord
sing hallelujah
hallelujah
god raise
and
hallelujah oh hallelujah
god reigns
forever all my days
[Music]
hallelujah oh hallelujah
hallelujah
[Music]
god reigns
forever all my days hallelujah
[Music]
yes
i will love you
and i will love you lord my strength
and i will love you
lord my
shield
and i
will you lord my
strength
forever all my days hallelujah
[Music]
lay
it all down at the feet of jesus
are you weary
and heavy laden
we bring it all to you jesus
bring your worry your grief and pain
every cause you have for shame
lay it all down
[Music]
when your cares have buried you
and there's nothing left for you to do
lay it all down
lay it all down at the feet of
jesus
[Music]
at the feet of jesus
and carried on but your heart was tired
feared the worst and felt the fire
little down
[Music]
lay it all down
fill with all those
those anxious thoughts all your doubts
become your god lay it all down
lay it all down at the feet of jesus
come lay it all down
at the feet of
jesus
lay it all down lay it all down lay it
all down lay it all down
all down lay it all down at the feet of
jesus
at the feet of jesus
when we're giving up on better days
those memories we can erase
lay it all down
we've come to fear all we can explain
there's nothing here that can ease the
pain
lay it all down
we lay it all down at the feet of
jesus come and lay it
at the feet of
jesus
lay it all down lay it all down lay it
all down lay it all down
all down lay it all down at the feet of
jesus
[Music]
come and lay it
at the feet of
jesus we wanna lay you down
jesus
okay we thank you
for being trustworthy and solid
and
a rock that we can return to
every time it feels as though things are
out of balance or
um
chaotic
or even sinking sand god we just put our
hope in you and
we ask that you would recenter us
tonight on you
and god we give you this time and this
place
to come and reign in our lives reign in
our hearts
renew us
and remind us of who you are god
lord open our ears and our hearts to
hear what
you've given brett to share with us and
we are yours it's in your name that we
pray
amen
if you guys want to just say hi to each
other and
turn and wave and smile and let the
people around you know that we're happy
to see you
y'all can smile with your
eyes it is
it's uh it's so funny how you can tell
when people are smiling even even with
their mask on you all the crinkles
little crinkles
uh some of us more than others i'm
getting
i'm in my late 30s so i'm getting more
more and more crinkles every day coming
in that's that's how it goes
um
well good evening everyone um
grace and peace i am
really glad um to be with you all like
maggie um
and mel mentioned it has it's been um
kind of a challenging week and i know it
can be you know different uh every
person you know is kind of on their own
journey and depending on your own kind
of sphere and family or
um friend group you know it can be kind
of different but at least in our our
kind of world and um
and even kind of the table family um
uh it's yeah it's been kind of a week of
of loss and challenge and really really
difficult so
um
i think
in a lot of ways i think the message
last sunday kind of has helped set
set us up in a way you know not to
get in a posture of kind of shaking the
fist at god you know
like how could you will this to happen
you know all that but um to
kind of be in that posture of like okay
god
we're um
we're moving forward and we're trusting
that you're good just like we're singing
you know you're good in the midst of it
in the midst of it so
um
so all that to say i i will see kind of
as i get into this message how things go
but i uh i've
i'm just a little sad today i mean
honestly if i'm just really truthful
it's just probably not one of those
sundays this you know energetic peppy
brett it's just uh
just probably not so much so um having
said that i think uh god is faithful and
he will
speak
you know through me that's what paul
talked about right
when i'm weak god is strong so
um
yes we'll we'll rely on that this
evening
i want to welcome of course all of you
but
especially anyone new
and
those who are online
we love you all lots
and
i also wanted to mention
someone very special so
there's uh james townsend has been
serving behind the scenes um for months
and months and months now basically
since we um
kind of shifted back to in person so
like april i think um and uh james has
so he's primarily an online community
member i think he's been here maybe once
maybe twice in person but he lives a few
hours away
um and so james basically he is kind of
our online host if you've ever
either been online or gone back later
and you know looked at the message or
something or the service and seen
comments and things so james is there um
and he's kind of doing it all like he
coordinates during the week um leading
up to the service with like the tech
team and what do i need to post and uh
and then he gets on early listens to
like music and sound and the tech side
and gives feedback to who's ever on the
tech team here and then during the
service he's like posting the links and
the announcements and welcoming people i
mean just like you gotta go on and on he
just he's just been um doing just a
wonderful job and he's helped us reach
people um that we might never have
connected with so um could you all give
him a hand
james
we love you
we love you um
yeah i'm really grateful for him so
uh all right so we are in um
part seven in our series titled
deconstruction finding god again
and um i've done an intro now for a lot
of times so i'll keep this orange row
short so deconstruction it refers to um
kind of that season of um of doubt
uh of wrestling with with kind of god in
theology in this sort of inherited
received beliefs
um that you picked up either through
sunday school or your church you know of
origin or just from the broader culture
um kind of ideas about you know
christian theology and jesus and
um
and yourself and sin and all the things
and so deconstruction is kind of that
season where you realize okay some of
this um is producing what the bible
calls bad fruit which basically means
it's a metaphor for results you know if
you think of a tree produces fruit so
what is what is that those ideas what
have they been producing what they've
been creating in you and um a lot of
folks will get to a point where they
realize oh gosh not so many good things
which kind of pushes us then to rethink
reconsider um and and kind of wrestle
the news that's what we've been doing in
this series it's kind of opened up space
to really wrestle with um
christian theology and
as you as you'll see though tonight is a
little bit of a turning point in the
series um which i'll i'll kind of unpack
in a minute
a little more along those lines so the
title of the message is deconstruction
and consumerism
deconstruction and consumerism and our
scripture is going to be from acts
chapter 17
um verses 16 through 23
and it says this while paul was waiting
for them in athens this is kind of his
like crew his missionary crew
he was greatly distressed to see that
the city was full of idols
so he reasoned in the synagogue with
both jews and god-fearing greeks as well
as in the marketplace day by day with
those who happen to be there a group of
epicurean and stoic philosophers began
to debate with him some of them asked
what is this babbler trying to say
others remarked he seems to be
advocating foreign gods they said this
because paul was preaching the good news
about jesus and the resurrection
then they took him and brought him to a
meeting of the areopagus where they said
to him may we know what this new
teaching is that you were presenting you
were bringing some strange ideas to our
ears and we would like to know what they
mean
you got a little parentheses all the
athenians and the foreigners who lived
there spent their time doing nothing but
talking about and listening to the
latest ideas uh if you know anything
about greek culture you know plato
aristotle like this is that it's athens
like it's that culture so it's kind of
interesting when the bible you know
historically kind of hooks up with
things that
you know even if you didn't have the
bible we would already kind of know that
about the culture so
that's interesting
verse 22. paul then stood up in the
meeting of the areopagus and said
people of athens i see that in every way
you are very religious
for as i walked around and looked
carefully at your objects of worship i
even found an altar with this
inscription to an unknown god
so you are ignorant of the very thing
you worship
and this is what i'm going to proclaim
to you
so uh tonight i'd like us to
kind of uh
set our our
um kind of turn our sights towards our
modern era
and it's it's what the the philosopher
charles taylor he calls it our secular
age
and um well i've spent the last few
weeks kind of deconstructing christian
theology um
we're gonna kind of shift a little bit
and start to do that with um our broader
culture
um
and
the i guess some of the reason the why
behind that is something i've noticed is
that when folks get into a pretty
intense season of deconstruction in
relationship to christianity um
they're often i mean just to be clear if
you haven't been here for previous weeks
like it's it's often a good thing right
like you're wrestling with things that
need to be kind of wrestled with thought
through maybe push back on um so that's
it's a good process um but but sometimes
uh the kind of the end point of all the
deconstruction is really just sort of a
destruction and kind of christian faith
is dismantled and it's kind of like okay
this is all dumb and i'm done with this
you know and what's interesting is
you'll
get in kind of a mode of being of asking
like tough questions having kind of
brutally honest conversations i mean
thinking hard like you're really pushing
these ideas out when it comes to
christian faith
but then as you start to leave christian
faith something i've seen is um that
often people suddenly
kind of lose that whole mode
and and kind of become completely
sort of open and honestly somewhat naive
about the new religions that they are
taking in
does that make sense so over here it's
sort of like
we're doing the hard work and you know
there's even a little bit of cynicism at
times um sometimes
just to be clear i don't want to be
defensive so well deserved because you
know churches can be crappy
so sometimes i deserve but right then
you kind of transition out and now it's
all of a sudden like yay you know it's
just all sunshine and rainbows and
anything's better than christianity you
know and i just think so uh so that's
where i'd like to go a little bit in the
next few weeks um
is to to kind of start to deconstruct
some of our um
north dallas religion
so
a few weeks ago i had coffee
with a friend and um he is he's he's a
wonderful guy he's about my age kind of
late 30s
um he really from the outside looking in
well i should say before that um so he's
not necessarily like
uh hasn't really been raised like in the
christian tradition wasn't really much
of a church go where his parents really
weren't i think he like sporadically
attended maybe a youth group here and
there and then in his 20s depending on
who he dated occasionally with like okay
she's a churchgoer sure sure i'll go you
know but
it was just never like his thing
um
and so he
uh
i've known enough for years and years so
all the way through the 20s and now in
his late 30s honestly he has at least
from the outside looking in i mean he is
just doing fantastic he's just killing
it like
all of the kind of cultural expectations
sort of like the guy that's just winning
and doing it all it's i mean it's really
quite remarkable he is he's very
intelligent uh he pretty early got into
the kind of technology spaces in his
early 20s which was a great kind of
career move
um
he started a company with a few friends
maybe i don't know maybe 10 years
eight or nine years ago um that company
just it just took off
is doing amazing so because of this he
is like kind of at the pinnacle for our
culture of a success i mean
he he has the loft in dallas
um eats at all the fancy restaurants
he drives the very fancy car i remember
um we would have like guys nights and
things and kind of hang out like friend
group and i remember sometimes i'd pull
in the parking space next to him this is
um i've now i've upgraded so now i have
a ford fiesta which is pretty fancy
um before that i was driving 2004 um
nissan sentra
oh yeah that thing was like 0 to 60 and
like five minutes or so yeah
um and i remember i would pull in and i
would pull in next to his tesla
and honestly i was happy for him you
know i was kind of like yeah good for
you but
i think i was just honestly feeling a
little bit insecure you know so i give
myself a little pep talks like brett
it's okay you are a success in your own
way you know
um
so he's just i mean it's amazing he
really and and i mean on top of that
he's like tall handsome i'm just kind of
like jeez dude he's just he's killing it
just doing great
um
uh and until about a year ago
and
he kind of hit this point where um
honestly kind of uh
emotional he just wasn't well
and he started um having panic attacks
not just like occasionally but i mean
like every day every afternoon
um he was extremely stressed out
and there was a lot kind of going on
underneath the surface
even more than he kind of realized and
it it's what's interesting is how the
body you know it's almost like his body
and mind started to rebel against
this life he had been living you know
because kind of behind the veneer of all
of the fancy things and the toys and the
loft and the lifestyle and the woohoo
you know um
he's you know working a ton
and there was a certain drivenness in
him there was a certain um
comparison he was doing constantly
trying to measure up thinking like okay
now
now i've got here and now i'm
now i'm gonna be happy and he basically
he said he reached this point which is
what our kind of coffee conversation was
about was he reached this point where he
realized like what is going on if anyone
should be happy i should be happy why am
i not happy
and and he realized all of a sudden he
really hadn't been very open like with
his own life and he's kind of shut down
and um
he he because that was kind of weakness
you know to show like hey i'm not doing
too good or things kind of suck or
difficult like that wasn't a thing he
was ever saying and so he was kind of
all bottled up and suddenly the panic
attacks are coming he has to take a
leave of absence from his job and then
the identity crisis kind of hit because
now it's like
all of a sudden it goes from like well
he's got the position like business
owner like the whole thing like he's the
man and all of a sudden he steps out of
that role
and it's kind of like who am i
what am i doing
why am i not happy
this is
this is not
like i got there i got where i wanted to
get and yet this is not working
why is this not working and as i'm
listening to him process all of this
um
it hits me
that he is in a season of deconstruction
but he's not deconstructing christianity
and those received beliefs
um he is deconstructing north dallas
religion
which is obsessed with image
and money
and status and position
like in that
that was his god and that was his um
his whole kind of life you know it was
wrapped up in that and so all of a
sudden um it's not working anymore
and
and he uh i mean basically began to
unravel
and it's it's so interesting because
honestly i don't think he would have
described himself as a person of faith
and yet
as i'm talking with him i kind of
realized he was
like he was a person of faith
he he was a true believer
you know he sold out for the cause
and um
it fell apart
which kind of got me to thinking um
about you know the apostle paul
and there he is in the areopagus and
athen you know all that and i'm kind of
wondering like what if he could come
into our day and what if he could like
walk the streets of dallas you know with
our uh our kind of business and
financial sector with its like billion
dollar businesses
kind of stroll through highland park
with it's i mean wow
mansions and wow cars and just the whole
thing i mean um
go to uptown go to deep ellum with the
arts and amazing kind of nightlife
um
and then he maybe even could make his
way out into the suburbs with the i mean
just masses just millions of people all
kind of clamoring
for
that vision of the good life
like and everyone's just going for it
and i i wonder like what would he say
like would he would he say
um
you know
people of dallas well i can see that you
know you have no religion at all you
secular people um or would he say people
of dallas
uh i see that in every way you are very
religious for i walked around and i
looked carefully at your objects of
worship in other words
um i just think you know humans we are
deeply deeply religious what do i mean
by that um we all have some big thing
that we're living into
some some people it's like politics and
like ideologies the cause
the kind of capital j
justice you know which can you well
prove that scientifically well you can't
it's a story
it's a story a big story
um
so everyone has an ideology a story
that we're living into
and i mean it's really it's kind of
mythological you know it's a myth it's a
story about what about um who we are
about what the purpose of life is um
about what the good is you know um
and what the bad is what not to do what
failure looks like i mean it's like it's
all um kind of there
and though you know we may not say like
god
um but something is at the top of the
hierarchy you have this hierarchy of
values and like something's right up
there you know
and so whether you say god or not it
functions like um like god
and so um though we may not be you know
consistent churchgoers like were
immersed in the religious rituals of
consumerism um endless like back in the
day it was probably the the liturgy of
the shopping mall
you know it was kind of that experience
of like that was sort of the
cultural insight it's like our temple
you know um and now it's kind of
different now those are all dying so now
it's like online you know endlessly
scrolling on the social media feeds
comparing our at times pitiful lives to
the patron saints you know the
influencers in their like fake
lamborghinis that they just rented like
earlier that day for an hour but you
know they gotta give you the good life
they gotta have they need true believers
you know so
uh and we're all just like yes clamoring
for the vision of you know being more
beautiful being i'm just what it's all
kind of the same thing it's this very um
strange um strange religion here's a
philosopher and christian james k smith
uh he says this you have to wager
it is not up to you you are already
committed you can't not bet your life on
something you can't not be headed
somewhere we live leaning forward
bent on arriving at the place that we
long for right this is his argument for
why everyone's religious
because we're all got that vision of the
good life and we're like headed for it
hardcore um so the question is what do
you long for
that's the question what what is it your
heart is longing for what do you long
for um what do you love
and how beautiful
and profound is it
or how shallow
and vapid
and stupid
that's the question
i think of an example of of kind of
stupid would be a cruel devil and 101
dalmatians
she has this line where you know like
she's always sort of screaming she says
i live for furs
i worship first um that's a good example
of stupid you know it's just like okay
um
and yet i don't how are we all that
different you know
um
there's a novelist david foster wallace
this is a lengthy quote from him but he
gave this wonderful um
speech which you can find online some of
you may have heard it this is water
um it's a commencement speech he gave to
kenyon college and as far as i know um
david foster wallace i mean he was just
kind of a so-called you know kind of
secular so to speak wasn't religious in
the classic sense you know
um
but it's really interesting this quote
is towards the end of his life right
before his his tragic death
uh and he's speaking to you know these
college graduates and this is this is
what he said
here's something else that's weird but
true
in the day-to-day trenches of adult life
there's actually no such thing as
atheism
there's no such thing as not worshiping
everybody worships
the only choice we get is what to
worship
and the compelling reason for maybe
choosing some sort of god or spiritual
type thing to worship be it jc
jesus christ of course or allah be it
yahweh or the wiccan mother goddess or
the four noble truths or some invaluable
set of ethical principles is that pretty
much anything else you worship will eat
you
alive
if you worship money and things if
they're where you tap real meaning in
life then you will never have enough
never feel you have enough it's the
truth
worship your body and beauty and sexual
allure and you will always feel ugly
and when time and age start showing you
will die a million deaths
before they finally grieve you
worship power you will end up feeling
weak and afraid
and you will need ever more power over
others to numb you to your own fear
worship your intellect being seen as
smart you will end up feeling stupid a
fraud always on the verge of being found
out but the insidious things about these
forms of worship is not that they're
evil or sinful it's that they're
unconscious
they are default settings they're the
kind of worship
at least in north dallas area for sure
you just
gradually
slip into
day after day getting more and more
selective about what you see
and how you measure value without ever
being fully aware that that's what
you're doing
this it seems to me this is a remarkable
moment when you have a so-called secular
speaker
speaking at a so-called secular college
commencement address and he sounds like
the apostle paul
people of athens
people of dallas
i i see that you are religious in every
way i have wandered around i have seen
your objects of worship you are obsessed
you are true believers through
and through
and
i love how he names that the big
question is
what are you worshiping
and then this ties back in with my the
story i opened with my friend
and is
it eating you
alive
verse 16
of acts 17 while paul was waiting for
them in athens he was greatly distressed
to see that the city was full of idols
i think often we think of idols you know
we think of little wooden or metal
objects and so then you know we don't do
that
um
and i i think paul would say oh yes you
do
i've seen your idols i've seen these
little these little replacements for god
you know i've
i've seen how they um how they function
and and the way these idols kind of
happen i think
um
is that it's back to that hierarchy of
values
right it's whatever at the top
what do you love
what do you desire what you long for
that's
god
and
in our kind of culture it's very common
or i should say increasingly common for
people um
to kind of you know we're not not so
much committed church goers anymore
right
but but we're enticed by
um it's what james k smith he calls it
the stronger magic
of the ever new glow
of consumer products and experiences
you know that's like that's our jam
that's our
that's our thing
um
and so i want to speak kind of in our
last few minutes here i want to speak to
um two groups of people so first let me
just speak to those who are in um kind
of a season of deconstruction with your
christian faith you know that's the
season you've been in and it's been
pretty hardcore what i want to encourage
you i think it's pretty clear from the
message but let me just make it really
clear um
the the answer to bad christian theology
um is
not um bad
secular consumer
theology
all right don't
like don't make that trade that's a or
or if you're going to make that trade
right like you can what you want
obviously i can't control you so do what
you want but i think long and hard on it
be slow to consider because we often
just think well i'm just leaving
religion you know i'm just leaving all
religion behind it feels so good not to
be religious anymore but that's the
thing right you live life leaning
forward you have to have a vision of the
good you're like
going for something you know and that's
the trick
uh and so be really slow
to trade um
the beauty of christ in his way of love
for
vapid empty consumerism
like be real slow in that trade
um
okay so that's the first group the
second group i want to speak to um are
those who uh you are not in a season of
deconstruction you would like i'm a
christian i'm all in you know um
and you might think you're off the hook
tonight you're like yes i'm all for
jesus team jesus
and uh i think we we kind of have to ask
this question
um
while we are saying kind of outwardly
that we are like yes team jesus you know
go christianity
um to what degree have we actually all
been co-opted by north dallas religion
without really
like realizing it
um
james k smith one more time he says you
could have bible inputs every day
and yet still have a household whose
frantic rhythms are humming along with a
consumerist myth of production and
consumption
you might have bible verses on the wall
in every room of the house
and yet the unspoken rituals reinforce
self-centeredness rather than
sacrifice
and that's i think that's the thing
maybe for the 90 of you who are like not
so much in the christian deconstruction
season this is the thing i think we're
going to have to wrestle with
um
and it's also why
i think as a church community we're a
little bit caught between a rock and a
hard place
because i think the tendency
um
for communities like ours is either to
go kind of all in on popular christian
culture
with all of its kind of baggage and
messed upness and lack of love
um or kind of swing and say well we're
not that anymore and kind of
unthinkingly start to mirror the broader
culture
and like not really realize what we're
doing does that make sense
and that's i think that's going to be
our path is like okay
lord how do we kind of thread the needle
here and walk this middle way
that's trying to reject
you know both of these
so that's um
so that's the invitation may we all kind
of take time this week to reflect
depending on whatever group you're in
you know
um
to what degree are we going down that
consumerist path because that's bad
religion too
real bad bad fruit it'll eat you alive
so
let's uh let's keep pursuing christ
let me pray for you lord jesus
we
we want to stay centered on you
even in a culture that um
seems to be trying its best to leave you
behind
and uh
but lord we know
that we are the easiest people to fool
to
and so god forgive us
for the times we've um
have gone and continued to go down that
that kind of consumer
road of things
that bad religion
lord we repent
we turn around we want to go a new
direction we want to live generously we
want to live sacrificially
we want to be people of
others other centered people
you know those who love well
so god set us free do that work in our
hearts and minds
we love you
it's in jesus name that i pray
amen
you brought me to the end of myself
and this has been the longest
[Music]
when my hallelujah
was tired
you gave me a new song
i'm letting
[Music]
go
i'm letting
i'm falling
into you
[Music]
i confess i still get scared sometimes
but perfect love comes rushing
in and all the lies that screamed inside
cause i learned
the moment you begin
i'm letting go
i'm letting
go
i'm letting go
falling into
i'm letting
go
[Music]
you
remind me
[Music]
of things forgotten you
unwind me
[Music]
until i'm totally undone
with my arms around me
[Music]
there was no match for your love you
want my
[Music]
you
remind me
of things forgotten you
unwind me
till i'm totally undone
with your arms around me
fear was no match for your love now
you've won me
i'm letting go
letting go
i'm letting
go
[Music]
falling
into you
thanks so much for being with us tonight
i hope that every part of the service
helped you to remember
that you are not alone no matter what
you're going through
and that god is bigger than we could
ever imagine and that he's got us
so just a reminder we have our welcome
to the table class coming up right now
so once i dismiss you can go right over
here and meet brett for that class again
you did not have to rsvp for it you can
still go there's still time
and then
also
if you're visiting with us we have
visitor cards out on the table outside
the door and to your right if you could
give us your name and your contact
information we would love to get in
contact with you this week
also our website thetabletx.org
has lots of information
about getting connected with our
community giving things like that so you
can check that out
so as we go out into our week um
hopefully
hopefully it's a better one than than
this last week um
let me leave you with this benediction
so if you're able go ahead and stand up
you are a child of god
and feel free to hold out your hands to
receive that
you
are a child of god
this is true on your best days
and it's especially true on your worst
days
so as you go into your week ahead
with it's yet to be determined highs and
lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance
that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these gifts
of unconditional love and grace and hope
to everyone you come in contact with
this week
be blessed you are loved
we hope to see you back here next week
good night
you